more than 6 000 people marched in memory
of 17 year old mile M the crowd led by
the dead teenager's mother
but the largely peaceful March turned
violent with some protesters burning
cars and police attempting to disperse
the crowds by firing tear gas
there was a palpable sense of outraging
grief here in the suburb of non-terre a
sense that Nile's killing is the
Catalyst for an outpouring of long
suppressed frustration
Nile was known to police but didn't have
a criminal record his family and friends
paid tribute
is a young man he's very kind he's not
evil or hooligan what the media are
saying about him is not true his mum
raised him well his grandmother we know
here around the neighborhood she's kind
and helpful she loves everyone the young
man left us for nothing we're not
contradicting the state we are not
contradicting the legal or police
procedure yes he was driving a car
without a license he tried to flee but
he should not be killed the original
police account was that the 17 year old
had driven the car at one of the offices
but video appears to contradict the
police version of what happened it shows
an officer pointing his weapon through
the window and appearing to fire at
close range before the car then pulls
away fatally wounded Nile crashed the
vehicle a short distance away
in view of the state of the
investigation and the details collected
the prosecution considers that the legal
conditions for the use of the weapon are
not met the officer is now being held as
a homicide suspect in custody at a
prison in central Paris in a country
where police impunity is widely assumed
that is a momentous precedent but it
hasn't quelled the anger in the banlier
suburbs of Paris and other cities
president Emmanuel macron held a crisis
meeting denouncing both the shooting and
the writing that has followed as
unjustifiable
clearly the emotion that comes with the
death of a young man calls for
contemplation and calm and it's what the
government has constantly called for I
think this is what should continue to
guide the next hours and the tributes
Syria Minister has ordered the
of 40 000 police officers across France
including five thousand in the capital
Paris alone president macron appealed
for contemplation and respect on
Thursday no sign of that here in
non-terre buildings are burning the
police have been firing tear gas again
in a cat and mouse game with
demonstrators and troublemakers on the
one side the authorities are appealing
for calm on the other side now's family
are demanding Justice
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera non tear